the rockies go with young right-hander
ryan castellani
eighth appearance seventh start of the
season one that'll bring up
jared walsh and this is pulled great
stop there by flett days to castellani
man oh man every night just like we do
with nolan
we talk about josh fuentes when he's in
there at first base
this is his best one yet though the dive
and then the lead throw to ryan for the
out
here's trout with two outs and mike hits
this ball
in the air to deep right center field
going back is blackman he'll leap and
make the catch at the wall
good play by chuck nasty angels down an
order
in the top of the first andrew this will
be
the heat dawg's 10th start of the season
three and three
charlie blackman the batter with two out
men at first base
blackman lines one out towards second
base and fletcher catches it before hits
the ground
baylor's have him loaded up joe adella
bound with the bases loaded one out
and it gets by drew butera coming home
as rindon won nothing angels on the pass
ball
so three walks and now a pass ball on
this inning i think he was setting up
for a fastball in and he got a slider
instead
he's the way butera reacted to that
you don't set up inside too often for a
slider
matt steps up to begin the second inning
with the rockies trailing one nothing
2-2 on ken
and kemp hits a high fly ball to deep
left he got under it a little bit did he
get enough
yes he did just enough matt
kemp with his sixth of the year a
towering home run to tie it
that went as far as it went high or as
high as it went
here's jared walsh 3-2
and this ball toward left center field
it's
going to be run down by tapia he held on
that's a terrific play by rival
make another star in the book that's the
third one i've gotten so far
in my book for great defensive plays by
the rockies
1-1 game here in the third with toppy at
first
and now two down so here's kevin pillar
there's a sharp hit toward left center
tapia can run this between her this will
get toppy at home
pilar is waiting a second rymel's going
to score standing up
2-1 colorado pilar's 20th rbi
there's that two out big hit here's
charlie
and there's a base hit pilar around
third he'll score
chuck got his way to second back to back
doubles make it three to one colorado
tenth double of the year for chuck nasty
nancy almonte the 22 and two thirds
innings
trouted second pull holes at first with
two outs elmonte and upton
right against right swung out and misty
got him with the slider yenci time again
shuts down the angels
3-1 rockies in the six the runners at
first and third
hampson will be the batter hanson shoots
one out toward right center field trout
and adele adele on the track makes the
catch
batter is jared walsh go ahead run at
the plate
two outs in the seventh back up the
middle
and story can't come up with it's an rbi
single
simmons will score the angels are down a
run stays hot
13th rbi for walsh
so lead off walk and albert pujols who's
had a couple of those walks will be in
the next batter
albert sky went down the left field line
hit well he's watching this one go
that is gone big fly number 660 for
albert pujols he has just now tied
willie mays on the all-time home run
list
congrats to albert the say hey kid has
been tied by the machine
albert pujols 660
career home runs 426th
different pitcher that albert has
homeward against
congrats to the machine albert
on that big plot first batter for the
angels
here will be jared walsh
that is lined to center field that is
going to get down for base hit a
multi-hit game for walsh
is he hot this month of september two
outs with runners at the corners
taylor ward first played appearance
this is hit over to third place nice
play by mcmahon has no play whatsoever
the run will score it's five to three
that goes an infield base hit
rocky's down to their final out with
hampton coming up now the payoff
swing and a miss light that baby up as
the angels pick up the victory
this afternoon by the final of five to
three and albert pujols running out
there
quickly to high five his teammates but
he was the story
of the game the go-ahead two-run home
run home run number
660 in his career tying the say hey kid
on the all-time home run list